just before Co hit we actually finished
we wrapped everything the week that Co
hit um and managed to do it on time um
and this was in almost 150 countries and
this was on the
BBC GM um really all over the place
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of makeawish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
ctec
Yoni welcome to my show 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being with
me I really appreciate your time and um
and and time you're about to spend with
me beyond the time that you've already
spent doing all the amazing work that
you're doing H today you're in the world
of Storytelling and storytelling of of
really high quality content that is both
educational yet entertaining meaning
you're working with some of the bigger
names in the industry uh either as
colleagues or as or as presenters of
your work ER and uh you're also your
background is not just in the in the
film industry but you're also coming
from Tech as well so it's an interesting
transition to to hear a little bit and
so I'm excited to dive into this world
with you tell me a little bit about
yourself you know how did you even get
into into the business init and what do
you really really care about let's start
there
well it's a big question to start with
um start B go basically um yes um before
I I had a brief encounter with with the
Hightech industry for four years uh in
the end of the 90s early 2000 but before
that I was writing stories um and after
that after the everything collapsed I
was going up and then I was crashing
down with everyone else um and trying to
figure out what to do with my life and
story 20 is that in 2008 or
2000 no that's uh I'm old uh that's uh
the it started 98 97
even and until the
2001 the Doom bubble yeah it was even
wor yeah yeah Doom bubble I was riding
the bubble and I was rushing with the
bubble uh going up with sun going down
wasn't that fun um but I'm happy it
happened because I had to look for
something to do uh so I came back to
story uh uh but then I had in this field
two different Ser actually I saw it down
as as a comedy writer and I wrote at
some of Israel's um most successful
comedies I I'm even the creator of the
only uh um Animation Show for grownup
for adults in in Israel a comedy um for
adults um because doing animation in
Israel is so expensive I'm the only
lunatic who actually did this um um
asked her about 15 years of writing
poies and being actually successful I
one day I woke up ahead and us I quit
everything I I was doing in comedy and I
started creating documentary movies
about
history um and I stepped out of
Israel and I worked in in for a Canadian
company for about six years seven years
and I've done um basically all my dreams
I've done a movie with James
Carol um and we went to for Atlantis the
L city of
Atlantis um going with the writings of
Plato we actually wrot about Atlantis
the first one uh looking for Atlantis
and amazing adventure at se uh going
really like quarter of the globe uh on a
boat looking for the L City uh that was
natural geographic and it was 171
countries around the world 171 count
even
bigger yes uh there's more actually
checked when they told me the number um
so um and then have done a
um a series with uh Samuel
Jackson um which was about the
transatlantic slave rate golden
slaved uh huge production 15 countries
just the the shooting was about two
years just before Co hit we actually
finished w we wrapped everything the
week that Co would hit um and managed to
do it one time um and this was in almost
150 countries and this was on the
BBC GM um really all over the place um
it was the first extensive 400 years of
slave
trade no one has done a a a show that
vast and that that crazy because we
actually went to the places and we uh
dived into six different shipwrecks of
of uh of ships that that transfer slaves
and we took stuff out to tell the story
to have things we can we can show to
make this into something real so I want
you to take me for a second and you know
sh you know walk me through your thought
process for a moment on what does it
mean for you to create these shows so
even going back to the transition from
from Comedy to history what what is that
all about for you
I I'm I'm doing what I what I like
basically I'm I'm I'm trying to fulfill
my dreams I had dreams about comedy
shows and about um animation shelves and
then my dreams changed and I wanted
to go around like travel the world and
tell stories about history um
and basically I I don't know how really
uh it actually
happened uh because sitting in in Israel
and having an idea
about
um about what second about the
um um the slave trade wanted to tell the
story um is one thing and actually
making this happen is totally different
of course I worked for a Canadian
company uh which was easier um and it's
basically having an ID a crazy ID
checking like they do with the Hightech
first of all you check if no one has
made something similar before um if your
brilliant ID has something similar then
there's no point of doing it and I
remember with sling I actually said for
a few days and and done research and I
it became clear that this is a huge
story uh you really have to watch the
show to understand
more than 12 million people were
trafficked and two million people died
at Sea
drowny um the num was just blew my mind
and the story was horrible but no one
has done anything no documentaries
whatsoever about the um what happened uh
you can find documentaries about
specific ships or specific events but no
one has maybe no one was stupid enough
to try to 400 years of History wild show
um and then when I when I realized no
one has done anything similar it's
almost the year of research of going to
universities around the world speaking
with experts and this is before the
actual shooting this is a year of year
of research before you even go and and
set it
out sitting in readings um uh reading
research uh talk to experts meeting with
professors organizing boats meeting with
governments because you cannot just go
out and and uh and start diving and
taking stuff out you have to speak with
the UN with governments
with it's it's really it's when I
started we we didn't know how how
complicated it's going to be but but it
was and after a year uh um the
U the person i' I've done this with uh
um actually we managed to to get Samuel
Jackson who we didn't know um and he
read our
um and he said I'm in I'm on board
I'm I'm hosting it um and we we just
couldn't believe it it was amazing uh
and once you have Samuel Jackson hosting
a
show uh you can start raising money um
and then similar to what if if I'm
creating it to uh to te is getting
Samuel Jackson to do your show is that
almost like getting like a top tier VC
or getting like the best like a like a a
a customer that is like you know top
brand that gives you this validation is
that is that almost like how it
feels yeah it's same it's the same and
then you you go and then you need to F
find money somehow you you you go to
channel uh and you try to sell the
product and they um invest and you to
get to 100% of the budget which which
was millions of of because about 1230
million um you have to get 30% of this
Channel and 20% of that channel and it's
it's another about six months of of hard
work of of going from door to
door um and uh at the end after almost
two years of work you start shooting you
actually open cameras and start shooting
and and and doing everything you Dre you
dreamed
about incredible okay and so from your
perspective you as the Storyteller what
what have you experienced by your know
what what's important for you in the
storytelling creation side so if I'm
putting the head off you know you as a
Creator now you're you're reading
something you almost like in an
entrepreneurial Journey what is that
what is important for you there
well how do you see your own creation
manifest through this work of
Storytelling what what I'm doing um all
my Productions is making sure it's going
to be something that young people would
watch because I I'm now for the past
eight years doing uh strugle
documentary which is um very easy to do
for an adult audience slow moving
historical uh uh numbers about something
but uh what I'm I'm I'm dedicated and I
think I'm sitting in in or doing is
actually telling the story in an
interesting way finding something
entertaining um because I'm doing
documentaries documentaries in a very
high or very high budgets um which means
I have to provide the Channel with
good numbers of of years um so if we're
telling a story about um the slave trade
we we have uh action of actually going
into jungles into Africa into South
America into the Caribbeans in diving
ships um um some of the stuff was
actually
dangerous um and it's great television
and it's a great way to tell story and
and tells give the audience information
while they're being
entertained um same thing of of all the
other stuff I'm doing always making sure
it's going to be interesting it must be
at the end it's television It's
Entertainment you must get the audience
attention um and the second that I'm
insisting on doing historical
documentaries should it be uh um
colliding with the fact that it has to
be
fun uh so I'm I'm trying to to make it
as interesting as possible which is not
easy right and I guess in in the context
of the type of work you've done it's not
always plannable you sometimes have to
be responsive to Dynamic to what you're
experiencing in you know in the world
because you're traveling you're going
around to different areas you're not
you're not in a studio filming is
scripted production always right so it's
it's a different type of planning and
mentality
you can plan it into instead uh you can
put yourself uh you can sit in the
office and plan the fact that you would
be on a canoe in a jungle in South
America looking for ruins over Sugar
Factory which I did and then when you
get to the actual canoe in the jungle on
the river you suddenly realize the
amount of snakes uh and alligators and
and uh tigers and the fact that you you
not the strong being in in this
environment and it takes a completely
different turn uh so you can play it
into H up to some point but then on the
field it you just have to flow with
it yeah that that makes a lot of sense
what what do you enjoy most about your
work if you think back over the last 15
years you know what is it what are the
moments which give you the most joy as a
Creator first of all when I have a crazy
crazy crazy idea everyone tells me
there's no way um you can make this
happen um if it's animation in Israel or
doing some crazy crazy uh
um 15 State countries should
something crazy with Samuel Jackson um
the the moment that I realized that I it
actually came through it actually um
happened um it started with with some
crazy idea in my brain and then went
into paper and then I started pitching
it around and then somebody joined and
then another person joined there there's
this moment when things
actually happen happened when when you
realize this crazy thought you had
actually you manag to to organize the
the money the people the research the
everything you need to make this happen
um and of course many many times that
everything didn't happen when I when I
organized everything um and everything
collapsed it it's very similar to to the
The Hiding industry um you can only
succeed in some projects not in all um
sometimes everything is good all the
people involved are professionals
and you can make it make it happen but I
guess in in Tech and Entrepreneurship is
there's a lot of question of timing and
Market how do you how do you um think
through timing and Market in the context
of your work is that also
a is that also a a an an impactful
parameter or is it or is it less
so of it is what I'm doing uh in the
past
three four years uh is is different I
I'm stopped uh uh traveling the world uh
all the time and I'm I came back to
Israel I I did I'm not not working in a
Canadian company anymore I have my own
production company in Israel and what
I'm trying to do is
actually um do something that again I
don't realize I don't understand how no
one have done this before um trying to
use the fact that Israel is sitting on
the verge the history of the western
civilization started here um thousands
of years of history and unfortunately
even today
uh we still fill the news with
everything that happens here so what I'm
doing is I'm trying to to create content
using the fact that I an Israeli that I
I have great um knowledge and
connections with everything that
everyone that working here
on archaeology History Science
everything that you can create shows
with or about um and I'm trying to
convince the world that uh um they
should buy it not from a Canadian or an
American telling the story of the Middle
East or Israel or Bible they they should
buy it from the
locals um and um it's sometimes easier
and sometimes like those day these days
it's um it's very difficult uh but uh
the fact it is I believe it's a it's a
grp great Economic Opportunity
because so many stories and by the way
like the high tech industry in the
television so many
talents uh so much talent so much uh uh
creation power uh um that should be
utilized to uh to create stuff for the
world so I'm I'm trying to duplicate the
itic
industry in in the television I know
that there's a lot a lot of very
successful uh content that came from
Israel scripted content um like fa and
and and other stuff even more successful
but um documentaries um didn't happen
yet and I'm I'm now this is what I'm
doing I'm trying to make this happen
incredible incredible um here on I want
to leave with a note for other
younger creators that are looking to
either break into the industry or to
tell their stories and and you know
follow the same type of interest that
that you do not necessarily in terms of
the content but in terms of going out
having this dream wanting to tell the
story even if it's crazy doing the
research and getting it done um what
what what do you what is sort of your
you know number one perspective for them
as they go on this
journey what
first of all
uh everything is possible really every
crazy thought you have if you sin and
you blend it and you research it well
enough and you treat it uh
um like a prodct like something that
that can be made into reality can be
made into reality even something great
he doing a show with with Samuel Jackson
that's number one the second thing is um
you have to be prepared for so many
failure um for so many projects that
crash AA things that sound amazing but
no one want them uh and and um the only
way to to find out what can be made into
a real product or uh will stay in your
head is is actually try to make this
happen uh so you have to be prepared for
a great number of of of crushing on your
face and
failing um with your dreams any jts but
you have to pick yourself and and and
continue the next day and change the
next dream it's the only way to to to
survive in this field and uh it's
possible I'm doing this for 20 years um
hopefully
for many years to come um and really
almost every crazy idea I
had or at least amazing number of them
actually happened and uh the uh painting
behind you it says the word optimistic
in Hebrew so I think that as you were
talking about ER what you just said I
was just reading that uh yeah that's
still
optimistic ER I love iton thank still
optimistic that's one it says
it's is his now but it was a very good
friend uh um one of of Israel's best
animator um and uh yes the the duck with
knives and and everything happened to
him but he's still optimistic that's the
Israeli B the story basically um
and and what I'm trying to do because uh
I I've been in this situation many times
that you have to keep on
walking yon thank you so much this was
wonderful continue making Amazing
Stories I'm excited to watch them myself
thank you for the inspiration thank you
very
much thank you thank you for the
opportunity have a nice
[Music]
day